this is a production of Cornell
University
so hello everybody and thank you very
much for me here I know it's very early
in the morning so I and so assistant
told you recently I used to work in the
midde Y at the University and I had just
finished finished my master's in which I
did my master in genetics and mechanisms
of genetic tolerance sorry
mechanism for controlling cold tolerance
in rice so I had just finished finished
my master and I was looking for a PhD
and was collaborating very closely with
Uruguayan rice breeding program at that
time I never worked for the UN program
but I used to collaborate a lot I still
do so I was looking for a PhD as I said
and they were so the Uruguayan breeding
program is a small and traditional
breeding program so what they were
trying to do they were trying to start
to thinking about how to implement
genomic selection of the breeding
program and since I was around I took
that task and I decided to send my PhD
project and this so what I what I try to
do is to explore some of the aspects
related to implementing genomic
selection in the rice breeding program
and I don't know if I did the best
choice but that's how I got here so
first of all what where's your way sure
way it's very tiny little country here
in South America and as you can see here
in this map is right in the limit
between the sub tropical and temperate
zone so for this reason the Uruguayan
climate can be classified as humid
subtropical so we have very well defined
seasons and so the most extreme of
course are winter and summer and the
winter runs oops sorry
the winter runs from June to August
where the average temperature can go
between 3 to 10 degrees
and then we have the summer season that
runs from December to March where the
average temperatures can be between 17
to 28 degrees so for this recent thing
rice cycle usually takes over during
this period and since temperatures
during the winter are so low or price we
can only have one cycle of rice a year
so then we usually don't tend to
associate your way right but actually
rice is not merely required but rice is
a third top export you're always mainly
an agricultural country so rice comes
right after beef and soybean and also
your why isn't top is among the top ten
major rice exporters in the world and
it's actually on the first place in
Latin America in 95 percent of the rice
production is exported so we're not only
a rice consuming country and for this
reason we have to need very high
standards for grain quality to be able
to export our product in the
international market and also as you can
see here in this plot up your wayans
rice yield are also very high are there
between 8 to 10 pounds per hectare and
as we can see here in the plot this is
the progression of rice yield since
1970s where the rice breeding program
was firstly established in the country
and we can see that how grains the grain
yields were increasing over time and
this was thanks to the adoption of new
high yielding varieties but also to the
investment in the adoption of new
agricultural practices and also a lot of
machinery investment however no so as I
said the high yielding varieties from
white were developed by the AMIA which
is the national sorry the national
cultural and the your wine rice reading
programs belongs to India and this
breeding program consists mainly of its
divided in two main breeding programs
which is the tropical japonica breeding
program and the indica breeding program
the
japonica consists mainly of lines that
were introduced from the u.s. in the 70s
and they were adapted to your wire
conditions and the indicator in plasm
consists mainly varieties that were
introduced from Colombia and there's
only three main three varieties that
were released by any account for ninety
two percent of the area anyway so this
main three varieties are it passes into
quality quadrant or Lamar which are
indica varieties and then there's a
tropical japonica variety which is in
Yetta body so the main problem we're
facing right now is that these varieties
are reaching their maximal the maximum
yield potential so we are and this was
thanks to all the improvements within
the agricultural practices and machinery
so we're really in the urge to develop
new varieties with higher yield
potential and but also yield is not
everything in rice grain quality is very
important too and since we export more
most of our production we really need to
eat those high standards and
international markets so the main
components of physical quality are
length and width which determine which
kind of grain we're having either short
medium or long grain and then head rice
yield is a very important component of
grain quality because red rice yield is
the weight of whole kernels
there's nobody likes broken kernels so
this is very important and it really
determines the price of the rice bag in
the market and then color is important
and also chalk is another very important
trade and chalk
because chalk really induces grain
breakage so it reduces rice yields and
chalk is this is this opaque area in the
grains that is caused by miss folding of
the of the amylose and amylopectin
layers during grain feeling so that was
this opaque area produces induces frame
breakage so this is a very important
trait to in cry
are also important because they also
induce breakage so we know that men and
quality traits and heal are the traits
I'm focusing here in my so and we know
these traits are quantitative traits so
dynamically genomic selection could be a
good strategy to improve these traits
and that's what basically my project was
was to explore different some of the
aspects of implementing genomic
selection to improve both brain and so
particularly I focused on evaluated the
impact of accounting for gie
and then also in the gie area I we
compared different ways to fit winner
covariance to feed our models and
improve our prediction accuracy also
another thing it was the use use genomic
selection to select the best
combinations of parents to cross and
start new breeding cycles and and this
is like a bonus track of the thesis
which is our finding genomic regions
that are associated to intercultural
response when we try to develop double
haploid lines for breeding so the first
time and the first thing I'm going to
talk to you about is to evaluate how to
evaluate prediction accuracy for yield
and meaning quality when we account for
gie in our germ plasm and this is part
of our work we published in crop science
last year so there's a lot of different
ways to account for you by statistic
statistically we were focused mainly on
using mixed models and so the mixed
model we used had this general form
where we have a trade our response
variable which is the measurements of
the trades for all genotypes in all
environments then you have our the mean
of the environment and we have this
genetic component which is a random
genetic effects and this random this
genetic effects have a normal
distribution with this covariance
structure which can be modeled by the
Kronecker product between two different
one environmental component which is
this Yui matrix here that represents the
generic covariance between and between
environments and this K is the genetic
covariance between lines that's the
genetic component of the model and
there's a lot of ways to there's a lot
of structures for these generic
covariance between environments so the
two who were focused only in two main
structures which are the actually
they're kind of like opposite which is
the diagonal matrix and the unstructured
matrix so the diagonal matrix what it
does it fits one single variance or
environment and it treats and then
there's no covariance between
environments so by this way we're
accounting is the same as fitting
environments or treating them as
independent and we're not sharing
information between environments then
the unstructured covariance matrix as as
as the diagonal matrix it fits one
single variants per environment but it
also fits a covariance between pairs of
environments so we try to compare the
our prediction accuracies with the data
sets we used where tropical japonica an
indica dataset that consisted both of
300 elite breeding lines and these lines
were evaluated in three different years
and the traits we use for yield merely
measure does kilograms per hectare then
milling yield head writes percentage and
grain chalkiness these are three the
three main components of quality in
plant height I'm going to explain now
how we phenotype these traits because
we're going to refer to them along the
whole presentation so when we first get
our harvest our rice from the field we
get our patty broth the paddy rice or
rough rice which is the grains that's
still there still attached to the whole
so we have to do all these grains to
obtain the brown rice this brown rice
will go then
will pass through the mill and it will
be to obtain the white Christ
after milling we're gonna pain we're
going to attend our white dress with
this it constitutes of both whole
Colonels and also broken Colonels so the
total amount of both whole and broken
Colonels is a million you relative to
the original then the head rise is only
when we separate both broken from whole
Colonels is the total amount of whole
Colonels relative to the original amount
of rice and then chalkiness is the third
component which is measured as total
chalky rice over the total milk rice and
chalky grain is a grain is considered as
chocolate ice chalky sorry when the
chalky area is more than 50 percent of
the total brain area for so we used
several cross-validation schemes here
I'm going to show you just a few of them
so we have we used a cross-validation 1
& 2 where the cross-validation one is
fits sorry tries to predict lines that
were never evaluated in an environment
so there are new lines and the
cross-validation two predicts lines that
were in valuating environments but not
in others so here we're really using
information that runs through the
environmental covariance matrix and this
other results from the prediction
accuracy is for each trade in the indica
dataset and I know there's a lot of
things going on in this part but I want
you to focus only on this two pink bars
for each year in each trade these two
pink - pink bars correspond to the
cross-validation scheme - the one when
we try to predict I said we're said
we're sorry tested in some environments
but not in others using the unstructured
covariance matrix so then these are
actually the only ones that are kind of
like more different than the rest and
for tropical japonica we see
the same trend but not as pronounced as
with the indicas again using the
cross-validation - with the unstructured
covariance matrix we're not we can
achieve the better prediction accuracy
and another crossword engine scenario we
tested and I'm going to tell you when I
talk about today is when we were trying
to predict new environment so
environments that were never like
developed before right in our case since
environments are years we're trying to
predict future years using the
information from previous years and the
training population so here we can see
when predicting every each year for both
the Indy kind of tropical japonica for
each trade using the diagonal and then
structural covariance matrix and we can
see that in each case prediction address
is a little higher when using the onion
structural covariance matrix than so
actually using this kind of fitting
these kinds of models that allow us to
borrow information between environments
really help us predict our lines to
achieve better prediction accuracy so as
a summary of this part again the
structure models when you fit in usually
under the cross validation two scenario
give birth prediction accuracy stand
when using covariance matrices and also
using these types of matrices are
beneficial when we try to predict
untested years and also this is also
true because in the case of the
unstructured covariance matrix the
correlations of covariances between
environments were very high so for these
reasons this those high correlations
really improve our prediction accuracy
with these types of matrices and this
basically responds to the stable weather
conditions in other Y where there's no
major weather event so usually I mean
weather is stable there's still
variation but there's no big variation
right so using again using GBM models
that account for G by E and that account
for correlations between environments
traits so now this is another study
where we also used two body models but
here what we wanted to do was to feed
our models with weather data to be able
to model our environments in a better
way so the objectives here were to
explore different ways to include this
weather covariance in our models because
the problem that we have when we use
weather covariance can be similar than
when we use molecular markers weather
covariance can be too many and can they
can be correlated they can be highly
correlated between each other so it's
not easy to fit these types of models
and also another objective was to try to
study the genetic basis of G body in our
own classes so the environmental
covariance we used where they were
retrieved from the weather station in
the rice training program like right
when the where the lines were evaluated
in the same field and they were they
consisted of either temperature Sun
solar radiation precipitation and they
were daily measurements for all these
different components and basically we
know that this covariance they're not
going to affect on the same way in each
state of the of the growth of the plant
growth so we try to calculate so we try
to like try to short those covariance to
different stages so we can kind of we
can model it more accurately so we try
to divide our plans sorry our yeah the
the rice growth into three main
different phonological stages which were
vegetative reproductive and maturity
reproductive powering and so the prime
is that we didn't have the information
of which at what time in the field
plants were at each stage so what we
used to calculate this stages was the
flowering time and we know usually the
flowering stage from booting to
flowering takes about 35 days so based
on these measurements and we know that
plants are left in the field after
flowering for about 30 days for brain
feeling and knowing they're late the
date of planting and harvesting we can
calculate this stage for our plants in
the field so we calculated that were
covariates your averages over this all
these stages for both tropical japonica
and the indica data sets and here the
data sets we use were the same as in the
previous work the only difference was
that the tropical japonica dataset had
two more years of evaluation and the
traits used for grain yield had rice
percentage chalkiness and height than
height as a control for a trade that is
not controlled by the environment so
much and we try to compare two main
different types of statistical models
here so we have on one side the reaction
norm models that were developed by the
Harkey and the PLS are models which pls
R stands for partial list for regression
models so for the for the reaction now
your models we tried three different
models which one that only models the
genetic the genetic effects the were
model using this effects are random so
they were modeled using the covariance
matrix between in between sorry between
genotypes then we have a G + W model
that has a genetic component denoted
component in an environment component
and the environment component was
modeled using the environmental
covariance sorry the the matrix of
environmental covariance or the matrix
of covariance between the vertical
and G plus W plus GW model adds this
interaction term between genotypes and
an environment and this term is model by
using the multiplicative product between
the two relationship matrix matrices on
the other hand we have the pls R models
and basically what pls our models do
they decompose our data into latent
variables and these latent variables are
linear combinations and what they try to
do is to maximize the covariance between
our response and our predictors so which
here we try the pls T model which was
only using Martin's detectors and the
pls GW model using both markers and
environmental covariance and these are
the results for the sorry I I don't know
why they show they don't show up here
but these are the results for the
prediction accuracy in both datasets and
here in blue to predict each year so
here we're trying to predict new years
so the bars the blue bars here represent
the the reaction model and the red or
orange bars represent the pls so we can
see that for the indicas and also for
the for the japonica's was Mowgli from
the amigas the pls our models gave
better prediction accuracies or equal
prediction accuracy stand their reaction
norms but usually this orange part which
represents
pls using both molecular markers and
environmental covariance they they
usually give a little higher prediction
accuracy so we can see it here to
further japonica's so basically and for
these data sets we obtain better
prediction accuracy when using these
types of models the the pls our models
also as I said in the introduction we
tried to explore the genetic basis of G
by E from our germ plasm and what we did
was we perform a G was or each year each
trade in each environment sorry yeah
each year and we could only we are here
we can only find significant q tears
forehead rise and chalkiness in both
datasets we couldn't find any
significant cutie else in an environment
or brain yield so what we did here so
this all these cutie ELLs have
differential different effects in
different environments right so what we
try to do here was to test all these
kikyo's for interaction with our weather
covariance and we use this model that
was developed by Marco Marco hello city
which fits a mania environment effect a
TTL main effect aquí te lo environment
affect and the QTL by sorry kidding back
et al by environmental covariant effect
and then there's a QTL by environment
and the genetic effects which are random
effects here and what we could only find
significant interactions for two of our
two tiel's in the indica dataset and
we're both forehead and the weather
covariates were mainly related well
first of all we try with interaction
with covariance that we're doing and
this were weather covariance related to
precipitation and humidity for one TTL
and for the other TTL related to
temperature and basically the similar
situation here in the tropical
japonica's we found one key teal for
head rise percentage showed significant
interaction with environmental
covariance through maturity two related
to precipitation and humidity and for
chalkiness this key TL showed
interaction with covariance that were
related to minimum temperature and
precipitation and this was unexpected
because we
know from previous studies that usually
grain choppiness is in the tropics it's
mainly affected by high temperatures so
but usually the high temperatures in the
tropics the ones that affect brain
chalkiness are those are higher however
in other white temperatures maximum
temperatures that during brain fill in
stage they never reach they're always
lower that so it could be possible that
for chalkiness in in Hawaii and also
maybe another temperate or subtropical
areas where temperatures are not as high
as in the tropics maybe there's other
weather components that might be
affecting this trade it could be either
temperature or also like solar radiation
and there's some physiological studies
with you and within the UI and germ
plasm that the breeders are doing nude
or white that also point so that was all
about genotype by environment direction
here we're moving to a different topic
or what we try to do were to was to
select to explore how to use genomic
prediction to the best combinations of
parents for breeding and so what we try
to do here was to first of all for the
first objective was we try to see how
many crosses in common would have when
we select our crosses based on the only
mean which is easily predicted when the
progeny means sorry which is easily
predicted by the mid parent value or by
using a combination of both the mean and
the under variance in our progeny the
variance is a little harder to predict
we and for to predict the variance in
our simulated progeny fluid simulations
and also we try to follow a different
selection criteria for improving
negatively correlated traits so usually
in rice grain yield and milling quality
are negatively correlated so we wanted
to see different ways you can improve
all our traits traits simultaneously
this was all done doing simulations but
also we have some of the crosses that
were simulated here were actually
performing a greenhouse so we try to
compare our predicted values so this
cross is the progeny from those process
was actually evaluated in the field in
order Y so we try to compare the
prediction accuracy that we had for
those crosses with actual field data
from the field so this is a summary of
what we did we first started from a
training population that consisted of
three hundred tropical japonica lines
and they breeding lines these were
planted in other Y and we firstly
performed 19 crosses between these lines
of this our training population we we
brought the f1 seed here to Cornell and
we planted it in the greenhouse
so this families were in the greenhouse
and we advanced at them up to f4 and
then with genotyped everything then we
also perform a hundred and eighty five
random crosses between this nineteen
families trying to do by bare white
trying to cross individuals from
different families and the progeny the
f1 from these crosses was sent to where
we could only obtain 43 double-homicide
of 185 f1 seed here and all these
families worse than valuation so this is
just as I said grain yield and this
wasn't the exception so here you can see
that grain yield is correlated with both
milling yield and head rice percentage
and it's also positively correlated with
grain chocolate but what we actually
want to do is to reduce chocolate so
this positive correlation is undesirable
we use so to make the 19 crosses here
between members of this relation we
would perform a cluster analysis here so
we could detect by different
groups in this population and we try to
cross individuals between different
groups as a way to preserve the original
diversity in the training population and
then we try to cross also individuals
that were good for one trade so these
are the results as I told you we make
them okay as I told you we made this
process in the field and why but we
brought the f1 seed here to pour now we
planted in the greenhouse and we we
genotype everything so these are the
results and the simulation for each for
each for each trade so we tried we we
simulated all the possible combinations
between these 19 families and we
calculated the mean and the variance and
here we can see the mean the mean of
each progeny versus the progeny variants
here
so from these progenies we try to select
the top hunt the top 100 individuals
that we're either that high had either
the highest mean which is this which are
these red dots here and I'm sorry the
reference here I don't know they got and
then we try to select the top 100
individuals that had both the sorry
where the the the top 100 progenies
where with the maximum yield I'm sorry
with a maximum
mean of the top 10 of the top 10% of the
population so this would be a
combination of selecting based on both
mean and variance and in purple here we
can see the crosses in common between
the two methods which are depicted here
so here we can see that we have more
crosses in common for grain yield and
for the other traits we could maybe four
so maybe for grain yield you suggest the
mean of the between their parents to
predict our best process maybe that
could be a good option and it's the
easiest option but also for the men in
quality trades we might want to evaluate
whether using the mean between the
parents or a combination of the mean and
the variance in the progeny would be the
best option because we don't have so
many
and here this is to show you the
correlated response between the trades
so in the simulations - so here we can
see that usually of course grain yield a
milling yield in this between these 19
families they have a negative
correlation but for between granule and
head rise percentage the correlation is
not that so there's and we can see that
- here in the decisive distribution of
the correlations between the trades
along across all the colonies so even
though this distribution is skewed to
the negative side we can see there's
some progenies that still have a
positive correlation so there's still
room for improvement here in the
curation so what we try to do here was
to simulate sorry to try to select
different evaluate different selection
schemes to improve both and you see so
the main three first three selection
schemes we use for they differed on the
selection and which trade we were
applying the strongest selection
pressure so the first one was firstly
selecting based on temperature 10% up
10% lines based based on yield and from
there
selecting based on the other quality
trades and the second one was selecting
first for head rise and then based on
the other trades and the third one was
selecting first or chalkiness than the
other two and then we also evaluated a
multiplicative index where where we can
see there all the trade simultaneously
here and here this X is the value for
that progeny is the meaning for that
party mean for that trade and this K
here is the minimum value or its low
weight value or the highest in the case
chocolates for that trait in across
whole projects
and then we go so we took the the top 25
crosses from each that were selected
from each selection scheme and mean of
those progeny sorry and we subtracted
that mean from that sorry we subtracted
the meaning the training population
selection and so for selection scheme 1
you see that we had the highest response
to selection for grain yield but they're
responsible selection for the other
melon quality traits was very low on the
other hand using selection scheme - we
have a low we had a lower response for
yield but we had a higher response and
also the second best scheme was the
multiplicative index so this could be
something we want to use in these types
of indices when we want to breed for
these traits in contingency then this is
a so that was for the simulations and
this part is about the evaluations or
families feel so again as I told you we
only could recover 43 double haploid
families out of 185 f1c he sent so we
didn't have the chance to like
everything and everything and so we
calculated the means for each family and
since the problem we had here was that
this lines arrived too late but why they
arrived on December so they were planted
late actually 3 months after the regular
rice schedule so for this reason we
think that grain yield was so low if we
compared here this is a meaning the for
each trade in the training population as
a reference so yield was very low but on
the other hand for milling quality for
milling yield and hair dries the the
means for these traits were actually a
little better than the training
population
and this was surprising for us the mean
for grain chalkiness was very low
compared to the training populations was
unexpected because these lines were
during maturity they were they went to
they were maturity during during the
fall season so temperatures can be very
localized and but it was it's a good
result
because we want to minimize chalkiness
these are the trade correlations between
these families and the correlations are
low but again since I mean the
correlations between yield and the other
minute quality traits are actually non
significant but again as our plants they
were planted late and I will heal was so
low because weather conditions we can't
take this very I mean we this plants are
there right now in the field they were
planted again for a new evaluation and
appropriate time so we're waiting for
that data to to make more informed
decisions the results of this analysis
so the other so what we try to do was to
compare our prediction accuracy is for
these families with the actual data from
the field and so what we did with we
perform genomic prediction on our lines
but L had our prediction accuracy is
four families then we had the evaluation
from the field we ran both predictions
and the field data and we compared with
the top 10% and we compared which ones
which ones on up 10% for the predictions
where in the work correspond we're also
in the top 10% for the field evaluations
and again for grain yield we could only
find one family this family was in
common between the two rankings but for
but again since they were planted late
we need actually like better data to
to examine the role of genomic selection
for grain yield but here for milling
quality traits we found four families
out of ten
where in common between the two rankings
and forebrain chalkiness six families
out of ten
where common limit between the two
predictions sorry the two rankings so
again we are waiting for for more data
to analyze from yield but this is
actually this is promising for us
because could be a great genomic
selection rates in inverted milling
quality traits in rice so that was
everything about genomic prediction now
this is a bonus track and I'm gonna go
past here but since I told you we only
we could only obtain 43 actually a
little more they work before that we'll
have those families out of 185 everyone
see
so our eye were the hub low yield was
very low so we try to see what we're
trying to do was to explore our germ
plasm or after culture and the culture
is the is the process to obtain that
will have three lines in rice so we try
to to to explore our germ plasm for
genomic regions associated to enter
culture in in our tropical japonica
lines and mainly anton cutter culture
consists of two main steps which are
colors induction and plant regeneration
and these are the two main bottlenecks
of the process so we and we know also
that the response to anther culture is
highly dependent on the donor genotype
and usually indica lines are the least
responsive among all lines tropical
japonica varieties are usually are
easier usually to regenerate but there's
some variation
so our objective was to identify qtls
for college both callous induction and
plan regeneration in our top-load lines
so our data set consisted of 191 lines
that belonged to 50 families where all
the double hop look families were cut we
could recover after the agriculture
process and the traits were Cali
transfer third dish this is a measure
was a measurement of colors induction a
number of plants regenerated per collars
which is a an idea of is a measurement
of language generation and then the
number of panicles per each regenerated
plant this gives us an idea of the
bigger plants because usually plants
regenerate by not usually but sometimes
plan for generate and then we transfer
them to the greenhouse and they they die
or they have very low yield and then the
genotyping was done using an Xterra
library and we had a total of about 69
thousand markers these are the results
for where G was for callus induction and
here we could identify for qtls
that were in distributed along
chromosomes to seven eleven and twelve
then for plans for collars we could find
a lot more qtls we found a total of
twelve qtls here and some of these QTL
were in mainly this one in chromosome to
whistle was also co-located with this
one for induction and these key days
were also distributed along chromosomes
2 3 5 6 7 8 & 9
and finally for pinnacles per plant we
had we found a total of five qtls
and this this QTL also co-located with
this with the second TTL
found here for plants per Collis
so we made our literature search to find
which kikyo's word for these traits were
previously reported in other studies and
we found a total of a QTL to among the
one we found or previously reported
reported in other studies so um these
results are exciting of course this is a
first step we just identify the key
tiel's then we have to go more more
deeply into fine mapping and possibly
identify on CASL genes under these two
tails but this is um this is exciting so
that's about all I wanted to tell you
today I this is the acknowledgement
parts so now I want to first thank my
committee my advisory system a couch and
the other members of my committee John
Luke and Philip and also Lucia which is
in Madison now I also want to thank the
breeders in the rice prison program
anemia which we could get all the data
from them and also the people from
biotechnology and statistics and also
the current and former members of them a
couch lab we sandy and Cassie for taking
care of my plants and helping me with
the crosses and you Xin and Francisco
for helping me with older biotechnology
I sort of further bioinformatic analysis
and of course Giovanni Vishnu Mooney who
sadly left us too soon
Diane in front of Eid for sharing office
time and conversation so thank you very
much for me this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu